remember that massive ecological
disaster that nobody talks about anyone
it's been five years since the BP
Deepwater Horizon oil rig exploded
sending 200 million gallons of oil into
the Gulf of Mexico making it the worst
spill in US history a new report from
the National Wildlife Foundation shows
wildlife in and around the Gulf are
still feeling the effects dolphins are
dying at four times their normal rate
while twelve percent of brown pelicans
and 32 percent of laughing gold have
died as a result of the spill the report
also says that this spill has affected
endangered sea turtles red snappers
coral colonies and different species of
fish but these affected animals are only
a small portion of the 13,000 species in
the Gulf all right so I want to do the
story because it touches on two of my
favorite topics and things we talked
about here a lot
one being the environment obviously but
second sort of the news cycle and how we
ingest news and how we get outraged by
something and then we forget about it
the next day
so David you've been to disaster areas
all over the world you're living
actually living this stuff not just
talking about it like me how do you
think how are we supposed to manage when
this something happens like actually
still paying attention to it and not
just letting it be something they care
about for three days and then forget
about yeah it's a tough cycle I just got
back from Nepal two weeks ago yeah I was
there for the earthquake and during my
time there the media was really focused
on the situation there and now that I'm
back I'm seeing how we're sort of
turning away and looking at different
news stories and that's natural that
that has happened since the beginning of
news that something's hot for the for a
moment and then it goes away and it's
important that we are reminded of big
stories like BP to be honest I I had
forgotten about BP I mean it did happen
a long time ago but I see what's still
going on there's magic and isn't that
interesting that five years ago seems
like a long time to us I mean it's not
really and remember for those how many
days was that thing just spewing oil out
to the ocean everyone kept saying well
this is gonna be a hundred year
ecological disaster and yet five years
does seem like an incredibly long time
it does yeah and to see what's going on
there now there's clearly a lot that
still needs to be done yeah and so
that's one of the reasons why we found
it riot so that we can continue to
highlight really important stories and
sort of break the new system if you like
yeah just sort of keep going to the next
thing
the next thing and try and research
important stories like though yeah I
mean what can we do I mean you're
someone that's that sort of involved in
things that riots doing like what can we
do as people that talk about the news to
not forget about this stuff yeah I mean
I think it's like obviously there's a
lot going on in the world so you know
it's not that we're just you know we
have like some sort of like news ad D
but you know like yesterday the news was
all you know Amtrak obviously the
tragedy that happened down there so like
yeah I don't know I mean I think that
it's it's important for media companies
like riot to continue to surface things
like this that require our attention you
know I think that like when you're
watching TV it bleeds it leads mentality
can be counterproductive to you know a
sort of broader world view but I think
you know thanks to the internet thanks
to media companies that aren't beholden
to the TV broadcast news model I think
that they really have the ability to
make a change and keep these things on
our awareness radar you know how much of
it do you think is on us as the
consumers because it seems to me it's
not just like people will say well you
know when there are riots like in
Baltimore they focus only on you know a
cop car that's burning or saying but I
don't think it's that the media is
sitting around having some big
conspiracy about what to show as much as
that's what people watch so like is that
is is it us it's really us that's at
fault as much as the media companies
right I think maybe you do have to cover
something go away but then the important
things to come back and not just leave
it and continually move on and on media
companies need to remember that the
story is ongoing and so maybe you turn
away for a little while but come back to
the story and follow up on it so is it
not just the news cycle but it's also
Twitter pretty much like we're so used
to just stuff changing our our it's like
I mean really Nepal was barely two weeks
ago right I mean it seems already like
we're on and there was just another
earthquake wasn't it was a yesterday or
the day before so it's like this isn't
gone already and yet yeah I mean I think
that's one of the you know most
important questions of our time that we
need to find an answer to like how do we
sift through all the data and all the
information that's out there to find
signal amongst the noise you know I mean
like distraction today I feel like is
obesity of the mind and
you know and we've got to look to our to
the you know to media companies and and
curators like yourself like what I try
to do on Twitter you know to sort of
sift through the sort of debris de to
surface real meaningful content yeah
distraction is obesity Matt is that
yours make that up right just right then
there it could be a soup somewhere and
it just can't but I last thought on this
do you think that natural disaster is
get the coverage that they should so you
were just in Nepal as I keep saying so
did it get at least for those first few
days did it get the type of coverage
that it that was warranted yeah
absolutely I mean for the first few days
it was just blanketed everywhere and
that's what you would hope for what's
interesting to me is that we've had a
few recently that have gotten huge
coverage but haven't had the kind of
response that we hope for like the Ebola
crisis for example when that thing was
happening it was everywhere but because
Ebola came to the u.s. shores that was
there that was our focus we turned
inward right we focused on the guy in
Brooklyn who went bold and we forgot
about the real crisis that was ongoing
in Africa yeah so that's another danger
too yeah no let's make sure we remain
focused on what the real issue is and
give that the coverage another good
ending remain focused on the real issues
what do you think is is this the media's
fault is it just what people clicked are
you still paying attention to the
disasters that happened five years ago
let us know your thoughts in the
comments right now